tu deviens un peu plus les longs mois
d'août
le geste est précis assuré pourtant éric
du plan n'est pas boulanger à temps
plein restaurateur d'art de métier se
passionnaient produit du pain au levain
deux fois par semaine ce que j'aime bien
c'est comme tous les boulangers taper
pour savoir si ça sonne bien creux s'il
reste patron d'humilité de dans du pain
eric en produit depuis 25 ans mais il ne
le vends que depuis quelques années
jusqu'au boutiste il moule lui-même sa
farine car de sa passion de la
boulangerie est né un intérêt pour la
farine et sa fabrication
là c'est un grande qualité bio c'est un
mélange de
j'irai six ou sept variétés donc là je
regarde s'il est bien trier il n'y a pas
de cailloux il ya un peu de un peu de
baisse
y'a pas de chardons ça m'intéresse aussi
donc on est pas mal
il sent bon ce bricoleur multicasquettes
fabrique et vend maintenant c'est propre
moulin à meule de pierre
ce modèle avec pierre en granit permet
d'extraire 10% de farine en plus qu'un
moulin classe il faudra rentrer ici par
la force centrifuge il va être il va
passer sous la tournante être expulsé
sur les côtés et il va être raclée par
ces petits racleurs donc on a une farine
tu est très aéré qui a été très peu
mécaniquement maltraitées entre
guillemets de la céréale à la sortie du
four
chaque étape compte pour ce boulanger
passionnés et la quarantaine de clients
qui vient chez lui à chaque fournée
après ça change je pars habituel il a
plus de goût après ça dépend si on aime
le pain classique la baguette ça pas de
présente parfum que là ils tous les
parents une saveur différente soit base
aux céréaliers des fruits secs aussi ça
change vraiment du pain habituel et il
garde beaucoup plus longtemps de l'épi
de blé aux consommateurs ce meunier
boulanger a créé son propre circuit tôt